thank you for the introduction
my name is Corvair it's a pleasure to
have this opportunity to talk to you all
of you today the framework that I used
for the content is what do I wish I had
known as an undergrad and from these
lessons that I've learned how am i
applying them today in my role as CEO of
Zeus so this is an email that I wrote
about 12 years ago pretty much to this
week to Facebook where I was turning
down an acquisition offer that they had
given us and when I reflect back on I
know some of the mistakes that I made in
my 20s
one of the things that I realized pretty
quickly was they tended to stem out of
some form of impatience or just having
too short of a time horizon and you know
for me if even one of you left this room
today with a slightly longer time
horizon than you had before you came in
I would view that as a success I'm
actually really intrigued by how things
change for you in terms of outcomes when
you are sort of thinking on maybe a 10
year time scale or a 20 year time scale
versus just a few years so stepping back
for a moment I wanted to share a little
bit more about myself and obviously the
company Zeus and then I'll go into these
these lessons so I I took a gap year
before I went to university I started my
first company as an undergrad it was a
marketplace for college students to
trade textbooks and other things I also
invested in my first property as an
undergraduate in England my default path
was actually to go into banking into
finance and again I remember early on my
motivation seemed to be basically I
wanted to make money I wanted to get to
financial independence as quickly as
possible and honestly someone had just
told me that banking was a good path to
go down and so I sort of mindlessly was
on that path
when I was in the bank I remember one
day I sort of stumbled upon like the
Facebook of all the resumes of all the
graduates that were in my sort of cohort
and the cohorts before me and I remember
looking at the resumes and being like
wow these kids are really really cool
they've done so many like interesting
things and they're so accomplished but
then when I would see them in the sort
of Bank environment day to day they just
seemed like completely different people
and I sort of had this thought I was
like what happens between you know all
these sort of interesting things you've
done to get a hit in here and then like
the life you're kind of living working
in the bank and I sort of realized or my
takeaway was there was something about
the nature of that industry and the
nature of that job and working with a
really large company that kind of was
maybe like I know slowly sucking the
life out of you and and I had this
realization where I was like I don't
want this to be me when I look back on
my life you know I don't want to have
this goal of like wanting to make money
sort of override all of the other
interests and experiences that I want to
enjoy and so I remember the moment when
you know I had the startup from
University I was in the bank and I had
to hand in my resignation and I walked
around with the the letter of
resignation inside my suit pocket and
every time I tried to sort of like
muster up the courage to go to my
managing director and say hey I'm
leaving sort of chickened out and I
think it was on the third attempt I just
bought it out and I said hey I'm leaving
and he was super shell shell-shocked and
then I was like well you know I want to
work on this startup I want to see which
way it goes he actually you know he was
obviously disappointed but he pretty
much sat down and wrote a check for
16,000 pounds and he became my first
angel investor and so that was you know
something that I experienced early on
and after that you know I did this
startup in London for about a year this
was 2006 and the startup environment in
London back then was tough
there wasn't a density of sort of angel
investors or even other entrepreneurs
and it was quite a struggle and I
remember one of the afternoons
when I was just sort of feeling
frustrated I think I just googled
startup mistakes and I found a Paul
Graham essay which I think it's titled
startup mistakes or top 16 mistakes
startups make and point number three on
that essay was location and he just said
hey you know sometimes you have to get
to the right spot before you can really
make things happen for yourself and at
that point I sort of realized from his
essay I discovered Y Combinator the
early stage investor we ended up
applying this was 2000 the end of 2006
we flew out to Boston for the interview
I have a photo later in the deck from
that interview and then we got in and
then January 2007 I moved out here to to
San Francisco then you know that startup
was acquired it was acquired by a
company in Vancouver Canada I moved
there for a bit I took a couple of years
off after working for the acquirer for a
year I dabbled in in acting I did sketch
comedy um I went traveling for a bit and
then I think three years passed and I
sort of jokingly refer that referred to
that as like that's how long it took
that amnesia to set in and for me to
forget how painful startups can be
before I moved back here in 2012 did Y
Combinator again worked through a few
sort of failed start-up ideas before I
came up with Zeus in 2016 so Zeus you
know quite simply we provide furnished
homes for you know the modern
professional for business travelers if
you think about when you're being
relocated by a company they put you up
in temporary housing or if you're being
sent somewhere for an extended period of
time rather than stay in a hotel you can
stay in a Zeus and where 30 day plus so
we're not really a short-term operator
we're not trying to compete with hotels
and we're in these five major metros
today and in terms of our mission I'm
really sort of motivated by this idea of
making it easy for people to live
wherever opportunity requires them to be
so I sort of saw in my own life how when
you know I moved from London to San
Francisco things really changed for me
they really transformed for me and I've
also heard stories over the last years
from some of my friends where maybe
they're living in New York and an
opportunity comes up on the west coast
but just that friction of like moving
and dealing with housing it's so much
that they're sort of like well actually
I think I'm just going to stay here
because I don't want to have to deal
deal with all of that it kind of makes
me sad because I really believe a lot of
human potential is locked up in location
and if you can make if you can basically
increase mobility then I think good
things happen overall so just some
highlights today we have three thousand
residents living with Zeus we have
twenty two hundred homes we passed a
hundred million in lifetime revenue I
think it was last week we're at a
hundred and ten million revenue run rate
and our revenue is growing 4x
year-over-year and we're in our 285
employees which blows my mind okay so
moving on to the lessons you know I
touched on this first one about thinking
long term the second lesson that I have
is to really invest in sort of
introspection and knowing yourself and
the final one is this idea that your
environment impacts you more than you
realize
so if I could time travel and go back to
when I was an undergrad I wish someone
had told me this and I think it would
have really helped me so in terms of
thinking long term you know there's a
few dimensions to this on the one hand
something as simple as if you want to
accomplish something if you want to gain
mastery if you want to you know achieve
something it actually just takes longer
than you think it takes actually quite a
bit of time to get really good at
something so I was definitely very
impatient and I remember even you know I
I went on this entrepreneurial path I
was one of these people that thought
that hey the best way to become an
entrepreneur or to learn how to be a CEO
is to just like become one and now I
think I've shifted my thinking a little
bit I actually think if you do want to
do a start-up eventually it can actually
be really beneficial to go work at a
start-up a fast growing one and like
observe from others and learn for a
while before you sort of take the plunge
to yourself I now believe that really
what determines
you know the success of your startup is
essentially getting to product market
fit and anything else that's not focused
on getting to product market fit doesn't
really matter and it can just take time
for you to have insights or ideas that
can lead you down that path now also
related to this I think is the idea of
you know not really chasing instant
gratification
so as you graduate maybe there are job
opportunities that come with a lot of
prestige or maybe they come with a lot
of money and then there might be other
opportunities that maybe index a little
bit higher on what you're going to learn
or the network that you're going to
build and I actually think you know what
you learn and like the network you build
that compounds again so much over time
that again I wouldn't sort of go for the
sort of short term sort of perceived I
don't know external success and you know
and I talk about compounding I don't
really think our brains are super well
set up to just really understand the
full magnitude of how things compound
over time and especially now with the
internet and technology I think it's
it's kind of even crazier so coming back
to you know the Facebook story I
referred to earlier I wanted to share
something at that time you know when
they were negotiating with us Facebook
was valued at fifteen billion dollars
that was their market cap they had just
done a deal with Microsoft think they
were selling some ad inventory that
Microsoft wanted to buy for being but I
remember at that time thinking fifteen
billion dollars as a valuation for
Facebook was just absolutely insane you
know we were coming out this was still
sort of coming out of the dot-com crash
but the guys at Facebook when they were
negotiating with us they were like well
hey covere you know absolute worst case
for us we're going to end up a company
say the size of Yahoo and Yahoo at that
time was valued at about thirty billion
dollars so they're like they're still
there sort of 2x upside to joining our
company and they're like you know on the
upside on the best case scenario you
know maybe we'll end up something like
Google and at that time Google was
around I think 100 to 125 billion
dollars market cap
they had IPO din 2004 at about twenty
five billion dollars market caps are
there sort of 4x over four years but I
remember like you know Google was a sort
of once in a generation company pretty
much invented the the best business
model of all time and so that's how they
were sort of pitching pitching the
opportunity to us before I came down I
looked up Facebook's market
capitalization it's now six hundred and
thirty billion dollars so it was
actually 40 X what it was back then and
even for the people that were there in
it you know it's kind of it was kind of
unfathomable to sort of think about it I
actually first sort of heard this advice
actually from Mark Zuckerberg speaking
at startup school here at Stanford and
he sort of just said they when you're
thinking on a longer time horizon I feel
like you just you end up you end up
playing a different game to your peers
whether you know you think about the
competitive dynamic as a startup or even
just the choices you're making in your
life I also did some research on Jeff
Bezos when I was studying Amazon and I'm
pretty sure he went into starting Amazon
with like a 20 year horizon and I almost
sort of think like if you're thinking
about starting a startup you know ask
yourself would you want to work on this
for about 20 years I also have a theory
that Obama pretty much had a 20 year
plan to become president apparentiy in
one of his legal internships he said
this you you might sound crazy if you
walk around telling people you want to
be President so early in your life but I
actually think there are people that
sort of work to that timeline yeah so
moving on I found this image online I
don't if you guys know the sort of
alleged quote from Archimedes about find
me a lever long enough and a fulcrum and
I can move the entire world but I like
to think of the horizon that you work on
as the fulcrum in this picture and you
know the longer the horizon you have the
further out you push it and essentially
the more leverage that you gain so how
do I apply this to Zeus today when we
identified this opportunity in sort of
furnished housing you know Airbnb
obviously exists as a very large
marketplace visit but it's geared much
more towards short term travel one
approach I could have taken to solving
the problem is to just create a sort of
Airbnb competitor in terms of like a
listing side a Marketplace site that was
aggregating this inventory for this 30
day plus segment and actually there was
a company started by a GSB grad called
home sweet that did that that took that
approach but what we realized when we
were digging into the problem you know
we like to really actually solve this
sort of industry we actually had to go
full stack and be fully vertically
integrated and actually build
infrastructure around property
management and the whole sort of data
science structure around it to actually
solve the problem for the long term and
you know it was when again when I was
talking to some investors and you know
they want to pick they're a very
scalable approach and so on it was quite
tempting to take some of these shortcuts
but we were very much like no we don't
want to do that we want to build a brand
building a brand means we have to build
this infrastructure it's going to take a
lot of hard work it's gonna take time
and after a few years maybe we'll get to
a model that's a little bit more
scalable than what we were doing
initially but it but this sort of
attitude definitely informed how I
started this company another you know
aspect is the investors that you pick
for your company now there are investors
that might offer you a higher valuation
they might offer you more money but
again this relationship if it's so sort
of permanent when someone invests in
your company and they they're on your
cap table you have to be really careful
about who you get into business with and
you know again you sort of reference
them you do back-channel references but
if you have this mindset I think it will
really help you so in my case for my
series a I picked Gary tan from
initialised ventures initialize capital
and he's actually a Stanford alum this
world now gary has been around this
startup ecosystem for about 10 years he
was a partner at Y Combinator and I
don't think I'd ever
met anyone who had something negative to
say about him and I think for someone to
be in the startup ecosystem for that
long acting as an investor for no-one to
have anything really negative to say
about you I think to me that was a big
signal that this person has the
character the ethics and the integrity
that I want to build my company with and
so that's one of the decisions I made
and no they weren't a traditional
series-a investor there were an early
stage investor but we took that path and
it's actually really paid off
this final point about business and
principled decision
it's actually an anecdote I'll share an
anecdote that I learned basically
listening to Brian Chesky the CEO of
Airbnb so is that I was at this talk he
gave once where he was relating the
first time that I think an Airbnb hosts
home had been trashed by like a guest
and I think it was around 2011 and 2012
and it sort of went into the media that
someone you know booked an Airbnb and
basically destroyed the home and he
really wanted to make it right there and
then for that host but then of course
the lawyers got involved and the lawyers
started talking about liability and then
he started talking to his investors and
and they were thinking about you know
again what's the sort of scalable
solution and it took a few days and you
know Airbnb didn't really respond to
this situation and it started
snowballing and then I think about a
week after it sort of first I guess got
out into onto the Internet they
announced a $50,000 host guarantee and
the lesson that Brian sort of relays
from this is he feels like he was very
much faced with a sort of opportunity to
make a principled decision which was to
make the host right for whatever the
experience was that they had been
through and then there was the sort of I
don't know the business sort of
optimized decision which is like hey
wasn't quite a fault did you have
insurance and so on and he's like I made
the principled decision and I wish I'd
made it quicker and it pays off in the
long term and at Zeus today we're often
sort of confronted with these or these
sorts of situations as well and there
are times when it might be tempting to
make like the business decision instead
of the principal decision but we pretty
much stick to our guns and trying to do
what's right and make the long-term
principled decision it's best for
everyone now I know I've been talking a
lot about you know having a longer time
horizon planning for the for the future
I can also understand how this might
sound I know potentially stressful
because you might be sitting there
thinking well I don't really know what I
want to do and how can I think in a sort
of 10-year timeline if you know I don't
even know what I want to do like in the
next six months so I actually think you
know my second lesson of really
investing in knowing yourself this is
actually a necessary condition and it's
a foundational part to being able to
think long term and I almost think it
doesn't make sense to be making these
plans for the next five years or the
tech next ten years if you don't really
understand who you are in terms of your
values what interest and excites you you
know where your sort of curiosity lies
and you know I think about time again at
college as an undergraduate how do you
think it's a really good opportunity for
you to do a sort of breadth first search
on essentially activities or subjects or
you know I know human sports that
energize you and also in terms of
finding the people that energizing
energize you you know your your
so-called tribe I think this is a kind
of framework that I use where you know
what what sort of motivates me and what
D motivates me and at Oxford I was part
of the entrepreneur Society so Oxford in
about 2004 and 2005 wasn't a very
entrepreneurial culture like doing
startups was just not a thing
but then this little group that we had
at this student Society we started I
remember just being energized so much
with like the people who are in the
committee they were ambitious they were
dynamic they were
risk-takers and then I sort of
contrasted that to the environment I've
experienced in the bank and I was like
hey this isn't actually energizing for
me so I knew it wasn't for myself I also
received advice from one of my
professors at Oxford where you know I
stayed in touch and then after that
first startup and I was dabbling and
acting it's like I know I'm not a
hundred percent sure what I want to do
next and he said to me he said very
clearly he's like coal vir it's
completely fine for you to spend a few
years trying something to see if you
like it and he's like it's actually
completely fine you know if you don't
figure out what we what you really want
to do in life you know maybe even till
the age of 40 for example and when I
heard that I was like wow really like it
might take you that long to find your
real passion in life and he's like yeah
and that's fine and he'd been on an
interesting journey himself he'd worked
in finance and now he was in academia
but I think that really sort of took the
pressure off for me because I always had
this idea that if I spent a couple of
years doing something and then decided I
didn't like it like maybe that time was
wasted now I'll share a little story
about acting it was something I was kind
of interested in from a distance but not
really seriously and when I was in
Vancouver I took my cousin who's in film
school to an audition I ended up
auditioning I got into this sketch
comedy group I think they only accepted
me because I had a British accent so I
was bringing something different to the
group but whatever I rolled with it I
was really terrible for the first few
shows that we did and then started
improving and then I ended up getting an
agent and I started doing some acting
classes one of the acting classes I took
it was called the Meisner technique now
mizen is a guy I think he his his
preferred method of teaching acting his
method acting and the exercise that I
was doing was around how do you build
connection with your scene partners or
your the fellow actors in a particular
scene and so we did this exercise where
I had to sit in a chair opposite someone
and our knees were touching and we were
making eye contact we weren't allowed to
break eye contact and I think I
say something like I don't know I feel
this I am happy or whatever and he would
just repeat it and then after he would
repeat it I would repeat it and we would
just keep repeating it until one of us
had an impulse to change what we were
saying and we did this for like 20
minutes and it's kind of weird and
you're just sitting there staring into
someone's eyes repeating this thing and
you I remember I started feeling angry
it was a really weird emotion and then
we did it and afterwards the acting
coach walked came up to me and she's
like hey covere I think you might be
blocked alright huh what does that mean
she's like yeah I think he might be you
know a little bit emotionally blocked or
emotionally suppressed I'm like what the
hell how could you tell from that one
exercise you don't know me and she she
wrote down a name on a piece of paper
she's like I'd like you to go and talk
to this person so I was you know pretty
open-minded at that time I went and
spoke to that individual and it turned
out she was a therapist and I was like
show up I was like hey I just did this
acting class and the coach said she
thinks I'm clogged so maybe we can talk
about it it was actually really
interesting I think the the sort of
stigma around mental health has
definitely changed from back then and
this idea of talking to a therapist but
I actually realized I I had a lot of
stuff that I had been suppressing and
blocking and so you know quick backstory
my parents separated when I was seven my
father passed away when I was 14 I went
to an all-boys school in London British
culture we don't really encourage people
to talk about their feelings I think
generally maybe men don't really talk
about their feelings that much and then
also coming from a sort of Indian South
Asian background maybe it's just my
family I don't know like there's not
necessarily a lot of affection outward
affection there's a lot of love and so I
started thinking about for myself I
remember when my father passed away I
was really sad but I was in this
all-boys school environment and there
were certain things that would trigger
me that would and it'd make me want to
cry or just like remind me of this loss
and I basically was like there's no way
I'm crying at a boy school so I would
just learn to switch it off and I got
really really
they're switching off some of these
emotions and you know eventually I sort
of learned this about myself and then I
processed it and I started learning
other things about myself and this whole
idea of introspection was like kind of
alien to me but that one experience of
dabbling in theater and then you know
finding this process actually really
helped for me to set a foundation for
myself for like the next part of my life
in terms of what I want to do and what's
important for me because I just want to
make a quick recommendation for this
book excuse her the headline there's I
think chapter four in here he talks
about values and he talks about this
process of self-discovery as sort of
peeling back the layers of an onion and
more you sort of peel back the more
there is to discover but I read this
book and I thought it was actually
really helpful and I also you know I
mentioned that I think so Jeff Bezos has
this regret minimization framework that
he talks about and I think it's
basically this technique of sort of
imagining yourself at 80 years old or 90
years old and looking back on your life
and sort of thinking what are the things
that you will regret versus what are the
things that you're not going to regret
and using that as a sort of forcing
function to help you make these
decisions when maybe you're a little bit
confused about what what the best thing
is to do for yourself okay so how do I
apply this today at C's definitely it
was foundational for us in terms of
setting our mission so when I started
the second company I sort of knew that
like making trying to make money it's
actually it's a really poor motivator it
doesn't get you through all the sort of
hardships and the challenges that you
have to overcome to be successful in a
startup so I went into starting zuse
knowing that my motivation wasn't really
about making money it was much more
around personal growth I think that's
one of my key values this idea that you
know I like to learn I like to you know
meet lots of people expand my network I
like to be challenged like one of my
fears is ever is being complacent and
kind of stagnating and I think a startup
actually provides you with a really
amazing opportunity to keep improving on
these dimensions
you have to learn very quickly and and
you know every day counts and every six
months it's a it's a different job so I
went into Zeus with much healthier sort
of motivations and a self understanding
of why I want to do this and then in
terms of the mission of the company
itself you know I alluded to it earlier
but I sort of saw for myself how my
outcomes and opportunities changed when
I move location and when I was sort of
doing life planning as an undergrad when
I didn't really understand how things
how long things actually took I actually
remember I sort of I sketched out I was
like a twenty to thirty years like make
money and get financial independence
thirty to forty explore other interests
potentially around you know the creative
side and then 40 plus I wanted to help
people and maybe do social work or get
or get into politics or something like
that and so what attracted me to this
idea was actually I can just help people
through the mission of my company and
even you know I haven't spoken so much
about the real estate or the property
management side but there are a lot of
people that you know end up investing in
real estate but then they don't really
want to deal with the complexity of it
of being a property manager of a
landlord and it can also be quite
limiting like you feel like you have to
be close to your property to be able to
sort of oversee it and manage it well
and so we're also decoupling that on the
owner side in hiring actually one of the
books I read as an undergrad was it was
called how to achieve twice as much in
half the time
again I look back at that and I sort of
laugh it was all about doing things
quickly and it's not one of these
popular self-help books but it was very
practical and to the point
and in there he sort of really
articulates this idea of logic of person
and logic of position and so for at zoos
what that really means for me when I'm
thinking about recruiting is I'm very
open with candidates where I just sort
of asked them I'm like hey what do you
want to get out of this job what do you
want to get out of joining this company
and you can be really open about it you
know I've heard of some CEOs who say I
want you to be here for like seven years
or some long period of time and actually
for me if someone's like I want to work
at zoos for a
or two years because I very practically
want to learn this stuff if that fits
into the logic of position which is
basically what does the company need out
of this role what are the the goals of
the role and the goals of the company
then if there's some consistency there
then I think everyone's going to be
happy great work will be done and it
will be a good sort of partnership if
however there's any inconsistency in
terms of what your what the candidates
personal motivations are and what are
going to be the outcomes of this role
then I think it's better to just be
upfront and say like hey I don't I don't
think it's going to be a good fit I
don't think it's going to work now for
for the people who are at Zeus I've
tried to build a culture where I allow
people to be their full selves at work I
sort of I used to believe that you have
to have this divide between your
professional self and your personal self
and actually don't think again that's
true and I don't think it leads to the
best work I think if you can bring your
full self every day and be open about
who you are and what your motivations
are and again continuously sort of learn
then I think that leads to a better work
environment and we've also you know
touched a little bit on this sort of
vulnerability
I think vulnerability is a great way to
build connection and you know sort of
maybe even a bit of intimacy between
coworkers which then I think leads to
higher bandwidth communication and a
closer sense of sort of teamwork and a
lot of the challenges that we have to
overcome require a lot of collaboration
and so we really double down at this at
Zeus okay so final lesson the power of
your environment and sort of not even
though you're kind of aware of this but
just I still think people probably
underestimate it so the first experience
I had of this was you know maybe going
from Oxford to the banking environment
and how it was so sort of demotivating
and demoralizing being there and
from London to San Francisco and being
in in the startup environment being in
the Y Combinator environment and how
sort of energizing and motivating that
was and how inspiring it was then when I
was in Vancouver near the end of it I
was starting to feel Restless I was
trying to make I knew I wanted to do
another startup I was trying to make a
startup happen for me there but it
didn't it wasn't quite working and then
I moved back here so I've had these very
sort of vivid experiences where the
environment really impacts you know how
how you behave and what you're motivated
by oh so this was the photo from my Y
Combinator interview I think I included
this mainly because my co-founder and
cousin hodge looks really nerdy I'm
wearing this Superman t-shirt and so
just poking at him but you know it's
very easy to absorb the values of the
people around us and now I can imagine
in a competitive environment like
Stanford everyone's sort of on
potentially I don't know kind of like a
rat race and so you feel like you have
to be doing the same thing as everyone
else is doing but I would caution
against this I'd be really careful to
guard against like absorbing values that
aren't really your own because I think
again long term that's detrimental I
think you know again it starts with just
being aware of the fact that your
environment impacts you and then being
intentional about picking the right one
for yourself to succeed and I also think
this applies at all scales so you know
at the largest scale when I when I took
the gap you and I went traveling and now
I've lived in four different countries
honestly I felt like I couldn't really
understand my own country till I'd lived
in in a different country and so if
there are some of you who are thinking
about opportunities that allow you to
live abroad or maybe you're living
abroad by coming to Stanford I really
encourage it because gives you a
different perspective I believe
countries themselves have values and
it's quite interesting to see what
different things what different values
different countries have but at the
smaller scale you know this may be your
home it may be your workplace
and you know the people you interact
with on a day-to-day basis so in terms
of how I'm using or applying this lesson
today it's basically it's been the
output is basically the culture that
we're trying to build at Zeus so we we
focused on the culture right at the
beginning the process for us was we
decided on what our company values were
going to be very quickly I'll outline
them we were we picked to be customer
centric to be humble to be iterative and
to be transparent now actually I think I
actually think values in isolation don't
make as much sense versus if you
communicate them in terms of trade-offs
so for example if I was to pick hey we
should have the company value of like
having integrity I kind of don't think
that means a lot because when would you
ever not have integrity so when we talk
to people at Zeus about our values and
we say hey we have this company value
around transparency we're very clear to
say this comes with certain costs the
costs may be you know everyone's goals
are sort of publicly available our
metrics are accessible by everyone every
line of revenue every line of cost you
can dig in you can go and question it
and sometimes that can be really
uncomfortable you know if you miss your
targets it's it's there for everyone to
see
if you make some bad decisions like it's
out there but what we say is overall we
are willing to endure those costs to
live up to add value because I think
that's in their best interest for the
long term when we talk about being
customer-centric I sort of outlined two
things one you know sometimes you have
to forego profit to basically really be
customer centric you may have made a
mistake you want to make a customer hole
or it can also be in terms of your day
to day like job description like you
have to personally go the extra step to
make a customer happy you have to endure
a bit of frustration and what we say at
Zeus is when you're presented with that
situation pick pick the value
and you know and other trade off is
photo from one of our off sites where we
were sort of doing some some sort of
group exercises I think again when it
comes to culture you have to measure it
and you have to continuously evaluate it
so at zoos we communicate that we are
all co-owners of the culture every
single person that joins the company is
adding to the culture and they're
bringing a little bit of their own sort
of belief system there so in the
recruiting process we try and be we we
go really deep on screening for these
values and understanding who these
individuals are it's also interesting to
just see how the dynamics changes you
add people
I remember our culture when we were
about 10 20 people I remember how it
changed when we got to about 50 60
people then when we got to 150 and now
we're you know 250 plus and we're also
distributed across five offices because
we're a tech enabled player we also have
you know field and operational staff and
there's potentially a different culture
between them and the people that work in
the office and so we you know we're
mindful about it we've said that we care
about it we measure it we screen for it
and I truly do believe that you know
ultimately culture does eat strategy for
lunch and I think it can be a superpower
for scaling if you get it right and you
know we're still sort of in our scaling
phase but we are seeing how these norms
of behaviors that you can sort of set in
the early days they persist over time
and they really help you so as part of
this exercise of you know what do I wish
I'd known as an undergrad it was
actually also interesting to reflect on
the other stuff which was what was I
doing as an undergrad that actually I
still do today and has proven to be
helpful I think in my case like
curiosity has just really helped me it's
opened up opportunities it's increased
my understanding of markets of people
and so I really encourage you all to be
as curious as possible I was I think
innately risk-taker early on
and again in the grand scheme of things
taking some risks in your early twenties
like they're not actually as big of a
risk as you make it out to be in your
mind so if if some of you guys are
confronted with a sort of safe option
and a slightly riskier option I
encourage you to take the riskier one
you'll probably learn more in getting
out of your comfort zone is also quite
rewarding this this third point about
surrounding yourself with positive
optimistic and ambitious people I feel
like I can't emphasize it enough largely
I've done this but there have been some
situations where I've ended up in
scenarios where I'm not spending a lot
of my day-to-day with positive people
and actually it can be really really
draining and I think if you're wanting
to go down the startup path whether
starting something for yourself or
joining a start-up I would really like
focus on this because people who are
positive and optimistic and you know you
find ways to solve all the challenges
that you're faced with and if your
default is to like I don't know look at
the negative outcome it's it's yeah I
really do motivating and final point is
reading I love to read I read as much as
possible I probably don't read as many
books now as I'd like to my previous
co-founder on that first company
automatic in addition to Hodges Patrick
Collison who started stripe and I think
he's at the extreme of the spectrum of
like reading a lot he walks around with
books pretty much all the time but I
think again this all pays off and even
you know I wasn't so interested in
history really growing up but more
recently I've learned that you can learn
a lot from history someone recommended
to me this book called Genghis Khan and
the making of the modern world it's
about the Mongolian Empire which I
didn't know too much about and actually
the way it was recommended to me was
when I went on this fix of trying to
understand Jeff Bezos people that had
worked for him had recommended the book
is by saying if you really want to know
him like read this book and I found that
interesting but a lot of history repeats
and I think actually understanding
Silicon Valley history you know the the
earliest companies here there's the
semiconductor companies and so on again
there's a lot of patterns that repeat
and I think it can really help you to
you understand that history so parting
thoughts you are more resilient and more
capable than you realize now again as an
undergrad what I've seen happen in my
own life and for I know people in my
cohort is having these crazy goals they
seem crazy but then actually as you grow
a little bit older your capacity to
handle them just increases in stuff that
you thought was really really
challenging over time it's actually not
that talent challenging or maybe you
just expand in your capacity to deal
with it so yeah I would just you know
you guys are in a at an amazing
institution surrounded by amazing people
I would love it if you guys think really
big and if you think you know on a on a
longer term horizon than you were before
thank you
I think we have time for questions I
just want to thank you for being so
vulnerable and honest about your anybody
knowing yourself
I'm also a South Indian and I read the
news quite a bit he said could you pick
a little bit more of how learning about
yourself through that process kind of
helps you in your next venture yeah I
think so I'll repeat the question how
did the process of knowing myself help
me in my journey in Zeus so I think
first and foremost when I when I started
having that feeling of I want to do
another startup like when I was in the
first startup often I was like man this
really sucks
this is such a struggle like every day
there's some setback there's so many
sort of things that can go wrong it was
really really tough and draining and
maybe that's why we we took the early
exit on that one because we're just like
this is sort of too much to handle so I
think that but original motivation we
were just trying to make money in the
first startup that's like a weak
foundation to build the sort of
motivation for doing a company on when I
realized that actually what I'm more
drawn to is that feeling of being
challenged being an underdog not being
complacent being forced to learn quickly
that's actually what's really
interesting to me now and you know on
the one hand when I look at myself yeah
maybe I can categorize myself as one of
these sort of high achiever types on the
other hand sometimes I think I'm really
deep down quite lazy and I could sit
down and play fifa on the PlayStation
like all day and my way like doing a
startup and getting myself into these
sorts of environments or ways to like
almost battle my own sometimes perceived
laziness and so I knew that a startup
was basically doing a start-up was
really consistent with my core inner
value which was growth and then I knew
that I wanted to work on something much
more long-term than I had previously and
and then also you know maybe the the
sort of vulnerability piece was it's
okay to sort of ask people for help and
to get help along the way and you know
getting a coach getting a therapist
openly sharing more with your
co-founders and people you work with and
so I sort of went into the next startup
being like hey I'm gonna do this one
differently I'm gonna care about the
culture so in our first startup there
were two British guys I think three
British guys two Irish guys we would
crack a lot of jokes every day we had a
very jokey bantery kind of culture it
was very interesting to see how it
quickly sort of slippery slope to like
at times being kind of unfriendly and
toxic and I was like hey this is my own
startup and how did I let the culture
sort of become this way so knowing I
guess to some knowing what was important
for myself and what I wanted to get
right really gave us a good foundation
for starting the next company and and
you know increasing your chances of
success yeah
till it offers a little bit more like
your background of being from coming
from policy to working in a technology
startup and something bad like and
become technician found inspectors have
that thought of like not being what to
do next
cool to repeat the question I didn't
have a computer science background how
did I think about getting into startups
what I read at university may not have
been directly related how did I deal
with that and then what was the last
part of the question it's not ok and
then what was the final phase when I
sort of got into acting and other stuff
so ok if I play things back I think when
I was growing up I originally wanted to
be a pilot
and then I became short-sighted and back
then in England it was like if you don't
have perfect eyesight you can't be a
pilot
so that plan was shelved I was really
into soccer I wanted to be a
professional soccer player wasn't good
enough so that plan was shelved and then
I sort of had this like well I really
want financial independence because
after my parents separated for a period
like you know we didn't have a lot of
resources and I got this scholarship to
a private school and I think I developed
a bit of a chip on my shoulder where you
know I was the kid who was a little bit
different to a lot of the other students
there so I approached thinking about
University of my 20s with this mindset
of how do I make money someone had told
me banking was a good thing to do and
actually from that someone had said oh
you should read PPE at Oxford that's a
great degree to get into the city and
it's actually politics philosophy
economics it's not policy so I went and
studied PPE I was good at maths and
Sciences growing up and then when I got
to Oxford I realised I picked the most
essay based reading based degree out
there and that was also a big adjustment
for me so I tried to pick the more
technical topics when I did the banking
internship I met someone called Sachin
who he was also a gap year student he
had started a business when he was 15 he
was building computers and selling them
and that was the first time that I'd
encountered this idea that maybe I could
be an entrepreneur and start a business
I had not encountered that at all
growing up I had never thought that was
an option for me and so when I saw him
doing this business I was like oh
actually why don't you know that's the
thing that I could do at university I
was exposed to this entrepreneur society
I joined it and then I felt this pain
point where I was spending a lot of
money buying stuff that I was like hey I
know there's other students who have
this to sell why am i buying retail and
probably once I'm done with it I could
sell it and I just sort of had this
spark I was like well why don't I create
a website I was familiar with Craigslist
we didn't really have that in England so
when I reflect back on my degree I
actually think what was valuable from
doing it and being at Oxford was I
learned how to learn quickly and I think
actually that's the skill that you need
is a as an entrepreneur you never really
have to become the specialist on
everything core like the full domain
expert you can end up hiring those but
you have to learn various things to a
certain standard before then you can get
people to solve it so I don't really
think what I studied was so much of a
constraint in what I wanted the you know
going into startups and going into
technology startups specifically when we
applied to Y Combinator at that point I
had realized that I should learn to
become somewhat technical and I was
learning how to code and actually think
that's what helped us get into Y
Combinator because Paul Graham really
had this belief that a lot of leverage
essentially lies with engineers and so
when he found to sort of like business
kids from from England saying hey Paul
we're learning how to code because we
realize that's what it's going to take
to be successful that helped us get into
Y Combinator and again now I don't
necessarily believe that as much I think
really finding the right idea to work on
is the most important thing whether you
have technical skills or not I think you
can like work around that the quality of
your co-founder and like again their
values and do they jive with youth
that's a really important thing and then
to the to the final point you know when
I had this opportunity to like I think
Tim Ferriss refers it to like taking a
mini retirement a lot of people work so
hard in their careers and
think hey when I get to 60 L I'll travel
and I'll do all of that and he's
actually an advocate for taking these
breaks during your career when you can
maybe a few months or a few years I was
like sure I'm gonna do this being a
soccer fan I went to South Africa for
the World Cup I traveled I dabbled in
this acting for me honestly it was just
exploration I was like hey I have this
opportunity that I've never had before
to have unstructured time to try various
things let me try and see what I what I
get out of it
that was my mindset again there was a
little bit of like you know you don't
necessarily feel like you're being
productive or working to some grand goal
but I knew I was again being challenged
learning something new that buzz that
you get from being onstage and
entertaining people and making them
laugh it's it's it's quite addictive
actually and the process of creating a
show there are some parallels to like
creating a startup and again you
collaborate with the team and so on so I
just I was open-minded I tried a few
things honestly some of it felt a little
bit random and accidental how I got into
it but I had this sort of period where I
could take this moment to step back and
then you know I started well through
that acting coaching and I met this
therapist I started working on
understanding who I was and what
motivated me and then I sort of realized
yes I want to do another startup I want
to give it another go and I want to move
back here and honestly I miss in the
environment of the Bay Area I know San
Francisco today you know as a city it
has a few of its challenges and
struggles but overall the density of
smart ambitious people that you have in
this part of the world its unrivaled
anywhere else and like even within
America like yes there's New York and so
on but I think the people that are here
in you know the sort of seven square
miles in the city it's quite special and
you can be ambitious you can move
quickly you can take risks I don't
really know of anywhere else where you
could do that probably in China there's
something similar going on right now
that's similar but I'm not as familiar
with it do you think of your again
you